parce que nos vies se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
je t'écris ces quelques lignes pour te
dire que oui je suis prêt à faire un
petit bout de chemin avec toi ps quand
je pars deux bouts de chemin je veux
dire départ de chez moi arriver au
boulot puis le retour mais aussi
possible tous les jours
merci à toi le covoiturage c'est
convivial économique et écologique
avec le covoiturage saint quentin en
yvelines vous propose une nouvelle façon
de vous déplacer
les inscriptions et les infos sur
www.covoiturage.fr lotir et est-ce qu y
point fr
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro d' équilibre le
magazine de l'environnement et du
développement durable
ce numéro est consacré à la pollution
intérieure car nous passons en moyenne
plus de 80% de notre tente entre quatre
murs que ce soit à la maison ou au
travail et cet air intérieur et parfois
beaucoup plus pollué que celui de
l'extérieur pour comprendre ce phénomène
nous avons rendez vous avec un physicien
de l'environnement à lui vs qu venez
suivez-moi philippe bousquet bonjour
bonjour merci de nous recevoir ici l obs
q qu'est ce que c'est que cette notion
de pollution intérieure alors c'est une
notion je dirais que qui dans les
notions un peu émergentes notamment en
termes de formation puisque on s'est
beaucoup intéressé à l'air extérieur en
fait depuis 20 ans depuis la loi sur
l'air plus de 20 ans et aujourd'hui donc
on s'intéresse aux problématiques de
l'air intérieur qui comme vous l'avez
dit est important de ce qu'on passe
beaucoup de temps à l'intérieur qu'ils
soient dans des locaux pour travailler
pour étudier pour vivre quelles sont les
différentes sources de la pollution
intérieure
alors il ya en premier lieu je dirais la
pollution extérieure c'est à dire le
fait que l'air con à l'extérieur va
conditionner j'irai au départ la qualité
de l'air qu'on va avoir dans les
habitations dans les locaux
professionnels puisque tout ça circule
et puis ensuite on va avoir des sources
un peu propres donc à l'intérieur des
habitations ou des locaux professionnels
des d'habitation on pense aux sources de
combustion que soient les cuisinières à
gaz par exemple que ce soit les des
foyers ouverts de cheminée ce genre de
choses on va avoir tout les tous les
meubles tout les aspects collet
aggloméré etc
les peintures qui vont émettre des
composés organiques volatils on pense au
formaldéhyde qui est peut-être le plus
symptomatique mais il y en a
malheureusement pas mal d'autres et donc
ces composés lakiss comme leurs noms
l'indiquent se retrouvent dans
l'atmosphère assez facilement et donc
dans l'air intérieur
et si les locaux sont pas suffisamment
ventilé main peut finalement à
s'accumuler un peu des fois plusieurs
semaines plusieurs mois après l'entrée
de l'objet ou
ou du tapis ou du différentes choses
dans la maison en fait et puis ensuite
on va avoir les aspects je dirais
bactéries virus qui dans les locaux
notamment reçoit beaucoup de public
peuvent peuvent effectivement se
retrouver dans l'air transportait des
fois par les poussières qui vont s'y
trouvait aussi et donc déclencher des
problèmes peut-être de santé pour les
gens qui sont autour
en tout cas faciliter la propagation de
ces bactéries de ces virus
quels sont les conduites qui vont
influencer la pollution à l'intérieur
est-ce qu'elle des choses qu'il ne faut
pas faire on a parlé récemment des feux
de cheminée par exemple ouvert qui sont
des sources importantes de pollution
parce que c'est une combustion à basse
température
donc ça c'est vrai que c'est très joli
très bucolique mais effectivement c'est
des choses qui sont qui peuvent entrer
des conduites à risques après remettre
en circulation une quantité de poussière
importante par exemple quand on fait des
travaux des choses comme ça sans s'en
prendre des précautions ou ça ça peut
véhiculer aussi la poussière elle même
peut être gênante puisque chaque
poussière peut véhiculer une bactérie ou
un virus qui peut potentiellement
vraiment à l'échelle même d'une bactérie
un virus pour les gens au niveau des
prix mais les handicapés il ya la maison
il ya les produits ménagers aussi par
les produits ménagers oui vous faites
bien de le dire effectivement on en
effet des études
or par la maison on avait fait des
études auprès des personnels en fait qui
font le ménage dans les dans les
hôpitaux notamment et on s'est aperçu
que entreprendre un vaporisateur et puis
sert comme on fait tout ça sur les
vitres ou sur les sur les surfaces où il
a dans le cadre pour nettoyer une
chambre par exemple entre le faire comme
ça où effectivement le mettre sur un
chiffon et et l'appliquer mais la
qualité de l'air dans l'espace était
complètement différente hier quand on le
vaporise on va retrouver le produit
partout dans la pièce alors que si
effectivement on l'a on adopte une
conduite plus raisonner en mettant sur
un chiffon gens sont contents lorsqu'ils
changent les habitudes des gens mais
alors si on communique avec lui de
laufon bas à ce moment là on améliore la
qualité de l'air à saint quentin en
yvelines pour être un peu plus locale
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de la
pollution intérieure par rapport
notamment aux maisons qui sont
construites assez récemment tous les
habitats sont assez récent est-ce que du
coup c'est plutôt positif par rapport au
fait que c'est les maisons sont mieux
isolés par exemple c'est positif pour
l'énergie et si on fait pas la
ventilation correctement c'est négatif
puisque on peut regarder d'humidité qui
de l'humidité qui se développe et c'est
donc oui si on fait bien la ventilation
et comme idole bien l'ensemble est
positif
c'est à dire qu'il faut aérer soi même
c'est ça non la ventilation mécanique
fait le travail normalement mais il faut
juste s'assurer que le système perdure
que les filtres sont bien nettoyer que
c'est tard il ya un entretien affaire
qui n'était pas le cas dans les maisons
un peu ancien nîmois justement d'ouvrir
les fenêtres d'une minute et ça
suffisait pour aérer la pièce et
renouveler l'air et finalement avoir une
qualité de l'air est bonne
mêlant au niveau énergétique c'est quand
même mieux d'avoir des créations gagnent
isolé et si on entretient bien son
système de ventilation mécanique
voilà l'ensemble est mieux merci
beaucoup pour cet ces informations les
pouvoirs publics sont en train de
s'emparer du problème la réglementation
évolue lentement mais déjà des
étiquettes de couleur existe sur les
produits de décoration ou de
construction elles seront même
obligatoire à partir de septembre
prochain
le ministère du développement durable
lance également un dispositif de
surveillance de la qualité de l'air dans
les écoles et les crèches
à partir de cet été pour en parler nous
restons à l'observatoire de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines puisque nous
avons rendez vous avec un enseignant
chercheur en santé environnementale
giorgos rem vyckos leurs gosses rémi
causse bonjour jours on parle depuis
quelques années du syndrome du bâtiment
malfant qu'est ce que ça veut dire dont
la vers la fin des années 70 début des
années 80 il ya eu plusieurs
observations de symptômes de personnes
présentant des symptômes non spécifiques
et qui ont été associés à l'occupation
de nouveaux bâtiments donc des symptômes
qui peuvent être de limitation de des
maux de tête des symptômes respiratoires
vraiment pas pas quelque chose de très
caractéristique
mais comme ça représentait plusieurs
personnes qui occupaient un nouveau
bâtiment est que l'on n'a pas
nécessairement trouver une identifié une
cause on a incriminé le bâtiment dans sa
totalité
que l'on a appelé malsain c'est un terme
introduit par le msb 86 je pense alors
tous les polluants n'ont pas les mêmes
effets il y en a qui sont plus dangereux
que d'autres
oui absolument c'est à dire que
les polluants qui donne lieu à des
symptômes aigus ne sont pas
nécessairement ceux qui sont les plus
graves
mais si on raisonne en termes de charge
de maladies si on essaye de le comparer
je dirai les choses entre elles
c'est vrai que par exemple l'humidité
avec la les moisissures et les
infections à répétition correspondent à
beaucoup plus de mal a dit que le formol
que dégagent les cols de l'âme des
éléments d'aménagement intérieur mais
qui lui est conservée gêne donc voyez
c'est pas c'est un autre une haute
gravité mais pas nécessairement une même
dimension de problème mais il ya aussi
tout ce qui est source d'allergie à les
sauces d'allergie ça peut être par
exemple les moquettes ça peut être le
couvre lit qui n'a pas été changé depuis
20 ans a peut être désolé ye qui ont
accumulé des acadiens donc il ya des cas
de réseaux pour l'art effectivement
avoir des problèmes dans ce sens le
milieu intérieur dans son logement ou
dans son bureau
justement les pouvoirs publics
s'emparent un petit peu du problème et
les réglementent par exemple dans les
crèches
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de cette
cette intervention publique est ce
qu'elle est suffisante rapide le
problème c'est que tous les acteurs
d'une chaîne soit à peu près au même
niveau
est ce que toutes les mairies qui sont
responsables des travaux fait dans les
écoles sont ou qui peuvent des
intercommunalités qui peuvent construire
des crèches est ce que c'est la honte
toutes les informations et là la réponse
est non l'expérience montre que une
petite municipalité qui va le faire son
école va le faire a minima et dont le
dossier de subvention qu'ils vont
essayer de monter personne ne va
regarder si par exemple il utilise des
peintures non émissifs plutôt que des
peintures qui sont bons beaucoup quels
sont les publics les plus touchés par ce
problème de pollution intérieure
répliques les plus sensibles c'est
toujours les enfants les personnes qui
ont déjà des symptômes respiratoires
donc ça peut être des personnes plutôt
âgées
donc tout ce qui est fragile et donc
après ça peut être aggravée dans les cas
de défaveur sociale parce que ils
cumulent d'autres handicaps qui exacerbe
un tous les problèmes merci beaucoup
pour toutes les informations merci à
vous à saint quentin en yvelines l
institut de promotion sur la santé à
trappes propose des ateliers de
sensibilisation directement adressé aux
bailleurs
regardez les goûts sont dans ma cuisine
que faire pour éviter de polluer l'air
de son habitat autour de cette petite
maison en carton une dizaine de gardiens
de logements sociaux
à eux de trouver les magnette qui
symbolisent les produits et les gestes à
éviter des problèmes que ces
professionnels de l'habitat côtoient au
quotidien
alors on a un peu de tout alors
moisissures donc posée fin du à
l'isolation mauvaise isolation des
façades des fenêtres des contres des
fenêtres on a quoi d'autre on a des
infiltrations fuite
dégorgement
il ya aussi un problème de main comme
mon collègue a dit et bien sûr la vmc
ont un problème de vmc bien sûr qu'ils
seront il faut dire aussi que ces
bâtiments qu'ils sont un peu anciens sur
la proposition de la communauté
d'agglomération c'est le bailleur qui a
invité ses salariés à participer à cet
atelier de sensibilisation l'entreprise
faire quarante mille logements sociaux
en ile de france dont environ 2000 à
saint quentin en yvelines
cette thématique de la qualité de l'air
touche tout le monde même des personnes
qui n'ont pas vu on doit avancer des
pavillons de personnes locataires en
pavillon faut simplement savoir comment
ça se gère mais peut-être du fait de la
densité de personnes effectivement c'est
une histoire de culture des cultures
nous avons donc intuitive de personnes
de cultures différentes pour qui
peut-être effectivement voir un espace
ouvert sur l'extérieur n'est pas bon il
passa donc voilà il ya tout ça
effectivement en prenant compte entre la
transpiration plus les débris coq on
arrête on dort
ils disent que les oreillers c'est
vraiment c'est plus que des faire ce
qu'il aime c'est effectivement c'est
manger tous les squames de pau et qu'ils
aiment les lieux les milieux chauds et
voilà l'oreiller le matelas pour ça
parmi les conseils des astuces mettre
son oreiller congélateur pour lutter
contre les acariens éviter les plantes
allergisantes comme les ficus ou encore
les interactions entre les produits
chimiques
autant de messages à faire passer pour
ces médiateurs pour moi ils sont
excellents relais auprès des habitants
sur ces questions de quais de santé dans
l'habitat et plus particulièrement de
qualité de l'air intérieur et puis son
coeur des problématiques qui discute
régulièrement avec les habitants de ces
questions là où delà des 5000
intoxication au monoxyde de carbone
c'est la cigarette qui est le premier
facteur de pollution dans l'habitat elle
produit plus de 4000 composés chimiques
nocifs alors pensez à bien aérer au
moins 15 minutes chaque jour
ainsi s'achève ce numéro d' équilibre
qui vous aura donné j'espère des clés de
compréhension sur ce phénomène dont la
prise de conscience vous l'aurez compris
est récente
avant de nous quitter quelques dates à
noter dans vos agendas le 29 juin
atelier communication animale pour
découvrir la bio acoustique et se mettre
dans la peau d'un chercheur samedi 26
juin concert poétique aux écolos rock
tout un programme l'histoire d'une
graine qui veut devenir un arbre
majestueux par la compagnie thierry et
compagnie
ce même jour découvrez l'étang de la
base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines en balade à vélo vous
comprendrez pourquoi le roi louis xiv a
décidé son aménagement
nous on se retrouve le 19 juillet
prochain pour un nouveau numéro d'
équilibre d'ici là restez curieux la
planète continue de tourner et nous on
prend le temps de l'observer